So we have like this perfect storm of conspiracies,
the conspiracy ism and conspiracy theories
that are swirling around 5G mobile connectivity,
and it is now melding with the Corona virus
to create some amazing conspiracy theories.
So let me catch you up on G 5 GS, the fifth
generation, as the name suggests, wireless
communication technology and it has the potential
really to be a game changer.
The download speeds for 5G are 1 to 2 in the
1 to 2 gigabit range depending on which country
we're looking at.
That is a level of throughput that could revolutionize
what's possible with mobile phones and mobile
devices.
Applications connectivity really could be
a major game changer.
Now, before coronavirus 5G has been one of
the fastest growing conspiracy theories, including
health related conspiracy theories, as well
as sort of government surveillance type stuff.
The anti 5G activists have alleged on social
media and in various forums and blogs that
5G can cause in fertility.
It can cause cancer, it can cause autism,
Alzheimer's, the death of birds, sleep disruption,
hypoxia, just about everything in between.
There is no solid evidence that mobile communications
networks harm human health.
There is a seven year study on this that has
found no risks associated with the technology
that is used in 5G communications.
And the old conspiracy theories more generally
about radio wave radiation are also being
revived around 5G.
Despite those also having been extensively
researched and debunked over the last many
decades.
So then we've got the 5G stuff incomes coronavirus
like like a rocket and a whole new slate of
conspiracy theories argued that the two are
connected.
So I'll tell you about how this works.
One of the theories is the real reason for
5G with its fast download speeds is to enable
mass live surveillance too in detail.
Know exactly what every person on earth is
doing.
Maybe governments are doing it.
Maybe shadowy organisations are doing it.
You combine this with corona virus and it
gets very, very crazy.
So one idea is Corona virus originated in
China.
China has recently turned down some 5G networks.
So clearly the two are connected in some way.
Now, of course, there's no reason to actually
think that.
But one thing that's important to understand
is that there are two types of 5G signals.
There is what's called millimeter wave.
And then there's the sub six gigahertz of
5G signals.
The millimeter wave are the new ones.
The sub six gigahertz ones are also what are
used for 4G.
That's what's been turned on in China.
So even at its face, it's ridiculous.
But when you actually look at the details,
it doesn't make any sense.
The 5G stuff turned on in China is the same
as the 4G stuff just faster.
That's been around for a long time.
Another version of the 5G Corona virus conspiracy
suggests that the virus itself was released
deliberately as a pretext to get people to
stay inside their homes so that vast secret
installations of 5G networks could be done
without people noticing it.
This one's aggressively dumb because it's
not a secret that 5G is being rolled out and
then more generally there are all sorts of
kind of irresponsible, baseless allegations
like for example, those who are using 5G for
nefarious means.
Also, what, forced vaccinations?
And what better pretext for forced vaccinations
than Corona virus?
It makes perfect sense.
Now we could take any one of these and analyze
it for a long time.
I'm just giving you some examples.
Here's one other one that's maybe my favorite.
This theory suggests that the symptoms of
Corona virus are really not the symptoms of
Corona virus.
They're the symptoms of hypoxia, lack of oxygen,
which they say can be caused by five G signals
themselves.
This includes shortness of breath, headache,
dizziness, dry cough, seizures and fainting
doesn't explain the fever.
But the idea is people don't really have corona
virus.
They have slowly developed hypoxia and are
suffocating from the five G signals.
That's probably enough, but you now get a
sense of why and how quickly these things
become weaponized in increasingly dangerous
ways.